of a necessity of family drama is kind
of claustrophobic because a family is
self-contained what did you bring from
your family experiences to this role and
is that why your dad freaked out
oh no I think he just really wasn't
expecting to see that you know like that
a movie opens with me having sex in the
woods is not like what everyone's
betting on I should my family is is
actually not a claustrophobic family at
all we're pretty open and and my parents
have been together since high school
and they are sort of one entity so I I
didn't have much to bring except for my
fear of it falling apart of how precious
it was and that's a good place to start
that the family environment is so
precious and you think of it as
something that is unchangeable um but it
is in fact something that needs a lot of
maintenance especially as you grow into
adulthood
Abbey yeah I did have a lot to draw from
my parents were divorced or got divorced
and I was in the fourth grade
so I felt like I was young enough than
to feel like it's kind of how I grew up
like with my mom and then she was in a
relationship when I was you know the
next year and so I kind of had a lot to
draw from from my own family and also
yeah I was seventy or yeah 17 not very
long ago so I felt like I I was still in
high school in many ways because of the
tile and line which is a term that a lot
of people now don't even know what it
means young people here's a sense of
what it was like in 1995 when you didn't
have the access to the world that you do
now through social media and other media
what was it like - almost inhabit a
different time it was like the 17th
century as far as communications were
concerned to make that realistic I mean
I grew up I think I'm probably the last
generation that grew up without internet
in their house like when I applied to
call
which I still wrote it out and you know
like I didn't get to apply online and
I'm so I'm not like an Internet teenager
nor did I have a cellphone in college
just because like I wasn't allowed to
have one they existed but no one gave
one to me so I didn't have one but I
think for me the way that this family
operates feels very natural to me as a
human which is that I want to connect
face to face and I want the rules of
relationships to be would you do that to
me if I were standing in front of you
which is something that you know we
don't really have that question floating
around because of the internet there is
access all the time but also a sense of
entitlement paired with a sense of like
privacy like don't look on my phone
don't know my password but the phone is
a portal to everything like that's a
really unbalanced way to be and the
reason why the relationships in this
movie break apart is because the balance
is off and that you know like when there
is an earthquake in California there's
like a little shutoff switch in your
house it's like a ball bearings that
that tips to tell you that your house is
shaken and you have to go and like flip
a switch in order to turn your gas back
on and that's kind of like the delicate
thing that happens in this family it's
like it goes off and and it feels like
you have to pay real attention just how
to fix it and that Jimmy feels like now
kind of like an ancient thing and I wish
people would do more how did Jillian
Robespierre lead everybody through this
experience and hold everybody together
well first of all I feel like I have to
say that it is Gillian with RG and I
watched her in every interview always
have to say it's Gillian with a hard G
and I know her mother Judy who's a
lovely woman but I don't understand why
Judy did this together this is every
time and anyway so just to just just to
say that her name is Gurion and I think
more than anyone on that set it felt
that although the story in landline is
a hybrid of experience that Elizabeth
home and Gillian Robespierre both had
they're both women who whose parents got
divorced when they were 16 and they
lived in Manhattan but the experience of
really wanting to be kind of free in the
90s and coming into one's own in that
Manhattan is Gillian so in all of the
ways that you look to a director for
guidance and for tones are also sort of
plugging in deeper to ask her about her
personal experience and in that way it's
very dear and precious and you're aware
of her boundaries and I think that
circles back into a film that is about
you know bonds being broken but you
didn't feel that she was making you be
her no I have someone feel a little bit
like I'm being a little bit of Gillian I
worked with her three times now our
first film was obvious child and I'm
definitely being much more of her than I
am being myself which is like a
beautiful thing about being able to do
art is stepping into someone else's
experience and honoring that every what
was it like for you yeah I understood um
throughout time like traveling with
Gillian and Jenny and Liz just you know
throughout all the screenings I've found
out how much of it is actually based on
real events and that was nothing that
Gillian or Liz really pushed on us
it was kind of like here's the script
this is the story and you can create the
character however you want to I didn't
think she ever pushed anything on us or
had anything like that was wrong with
our performances so yeah she gave us a
lot of freedom but I did feel like that
this is Gillian
as a teenager I saw a couple of photos
too and I was it just makes total sense
but I'm not dressed yeah a lot of it was
similar well thank you both for that and
please thank Jenny slate and Abbie Quinn